your appropriate love it you can relax
you can relax
hello every time so first time someone
comes on they're always like I need a
comic right need to be professional oh
no no we don't have professionalism here
hi I'm Ryan Wright and I am Kat Wagner
Wagner is here I met her because I saw
her do a hilarious stand up at flappers
comedy club in Burbank she was so
[ __ ] funny I was like this girl has
to come on the channel so if you don't
make us laugh Kat it's gonna be really
[ __ ] embarrassing for you cuz I am
totally set you up to be funny tell us a
joke
ah come on monkey perform for me doesn't
work that way I know and I wish my
relatives would know that to see you
know you bring in the family cuz
everyone can relate the family comedy
class Ryan Wright 101 we're gonna watch
the trailer for Melissa McCarthy's the
boss oh it's a red band trailer Kristin
Bella's in it I used to have a big crush
on her you know she is Runk tomorrow oh
god she was she wasn't frozen was she
voice no she wasn't was she I don't
think that was her I would have known
that no why do you know if we're getting
Sarah Marshall she's in a bikini no yeah
it's her it's her she's in frozen okay
yeah yeah we are back with Michelle
Darnell the richest woman in America
let's talk about you for a second great
it's my favorite subject we came across
this tape the other day with your mentor
I to Marquette Michelle Darnell's a
natural-born [ __ ] Oh a
[ __ ] a [ __ ] stain and sewer rat
I'm on your operation while beating a
single mom I deserve a pay raise you
have a try oh yeah but that's ruiner of
course yes somebody [ __ ] you close I
wouldn't under arrest for insider
trading
you're a bankrupt all your accounts have
been frozen clear get me a new lawyer
you don't have any money you stupid
ginger you can stay here until you get
back on your feet this morning a meeting
with old colleague Carl has an old ball
and chain Pam passed away nobody here at
this table likes you so thank you very
much and goodbye you know what I made
your career and Pam was a [ __ ] she
[ __ ] up my journal home IT department
the lowest weirdest saddest guys go to
hell Michelle when I get to hell I'll
tell Pam you said hello cause she's
probably down there [ __ ] IT guys say
great things word and Alliance meeting I
too came in with the $189,000 oh [ __ ]
what is this this is my way back we are
gonna start a brownie Empire we want
some good recruits what are you gonna
bail Vecchio you know the train wrecks
always have stripper names
Mariana Gutierrez she looks brilliant
that's a deadly Bunch
you better run [ __ ] my name is Rochelle
Darnell and this is my partner that'll
be partner like girl want gray stuff
let's go girls
something you're gonna dabble with in
color not stick with I know don't tell
less your Hannah I think it's gonna fit
you like a glove
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
pelvic region is the color of curly Wow
funny woman yes something you can relate
to absolutely that was that looks pretty
funny yeah I want to see that Melissa
McCarthy is great at playing these like
sort of mean-spirited roles I like how
her mean spirit in this she does it with
a smile on her face you know like she's
enjoying it liking to her other roles
she's like straightforward angry not as
much of aggression but she's like you
think she's so much better than everyone
yeah you know like that seems like a
funny approach for her looks like she's
having so much fun playing it from an
actor perspective totally having a blast
like when else do you get to just be
mean to people
I know hey yeah you're a [ __ ] wait am i
let us say that I have to watch my
behavior oh no I have some Australian
friends and they just got me immune to
it don't have to watch myself because
you actually have a job oh yes I do I do
I don't get it though if you're a
stripper it doesn't really make sense
why this would bother people hey I'm not
a stripper I'm not a stripper you were
if there's anything wrong with being a
stripper I mean I'm not offending
strippers like that's it's cool to be a
stripper no it's then what were you
doing when I isn't flappers is strip
comedy Joey no they should have been a
strip comedy joint in Vegas oh I already
did it
yeah we're stand-up comedy while the
tripperz yeah it sounds [ __ ] funny
they should get a movie about that yeah
but back to this movie yeah um Kristen
Bell looks like she's playing off a
Melissa McCarthy well she's not trying
to like match her necessarily she's
going with the more subtle
straightforward approach and I respect
the fact that she's doing that they're
not like butting heads trying to
outshine each other they're not two big
personalities like they mesh well
together they mesh really well together
yeah is Melissa McCarthy like like
Martha Stewart inspired kind of mean
went to prison yeah I would say so I was
thinking Hillary Clinton the whole time
I was watching her okay
but then where would they get the red
hair I mean I guess that's just Melissa
McCarthy because she has red hair that's
just what she looks like she has red
hair reddish hair Brown that was brown
well we gotta get our facts right or
else YouTube is gonna rip us a new one
Auburn it might be like a tennis ball
thing you know you don't know if it's
like yellow or green it's just you know
and people fight about it I feel
strangely comfortable with you even
though I've known you for a half-hour
that's cool that's cool
I'm taking those cats oh don't even try
man so sad I'm so disappointed I can't
tell you you know 22 so many girls say
that to me and that exact tone too so it
sucks to let so many girls down yeah
Peter Dinklage is in this family I hope
he's not just playing funny small man
again because I feel like he's really
been like he's done a lot of those roles
like yeah we get it he's he's what's the
proper term little man yes a little
person is it is [ __ ] offensive yes you
can't say [ __ ] it's like the n-word oh
is it
Peter Dinklage is a huge fan of this
channel still I'm so sorry I'm sorry I
don't know the word to describe your
height
you're a little man okay sorry that I
can't do that either Peter Dinklage I
he's such a great actor that I hope he's
not just doing another comedic role
where it's like yeah we get it man
you're you're the short dude who's
happens to do physical comedy like you
playing with the swords
I'm hoping this movie has a good balance
of its physical comedy sometimes it
seems like oh it's the dialogue in the
back and forth and then they'll throw
and slapstick yeah physical comedy of
bits in there in those moments I wasn't
so sure like the fight scene with the
girls
when they're all like annihilating each
other that seemed like out of a
different film as to what the rest of
the trailer was showing me I completely
agree it's almost like you're trying to
hit like a particular moment in a comedy
like maybe are taking a formula from
anchorman yeah like an exact scene like
that and ball thank your man see ya yeah
I'm curious to watch the rest of it and
see like what else and that particular
scene might be borrowed not borrowed
borrowed like plagiarize but like you
know taking me do you wiggle it around a
bit change it you know that kind of
borrowed again she said wiggle it around
nice bro yeah all right take two hey and
she said wiggle scent take two take
three hey Ian she said wiggle nice bro
nice Thanks ah wait who's this actor you
got excited for Andy Macdonald yeah Andy
McDonald from MADtv is in this film and
I and any place is famous character
Stuart one right yeah that's where you
were doing that's where you're just duty
without me talking without me talking
without me talking do it again yeah what
I'm not talking
well anyway guys yeah I guess we'll be
watching the boss maybe I'll do a review
of it if you guys want me to sure if
you're new to the channel subscribe
today become a reject I call the fans
rejects and Kat Wagner you can follow
her on all sorts of social media how do
you okay how do you spell your name with
the C C 80 W a G and E and that's your
Facebook that is my facebook at
facebook.com slash Kat Wagner comedy or
you can follow me on Twitter at the cat
Wagner my Instagram is also the cat
Wagner so that's weird I'm with the Ryan
Wright yeah
great minds man great women think alike
get that right Ian I know got to watch
myself but you really set me up when
this cameras off I want you to fist bump
what and then say I want a fist pump I'm
sorry
oh god I love being 14 years old and
running my youtube channel so yeah this
is this is over